Володимир Зеленський перейняв у спадок від Петра Порошенка армію та флот
з високим бойовим духом і гарним вишколом, хоча й з низкою структурних проблем.
Високий рейтинг довіри давав Зеленському можливість
для радикальних перетворень у Збройних силах України.
Пообіцявши "нові обличчя", президент спершу призначив молодого
та цивільного керівника Міноборони.
Андрій Загороднюк створив так звану "візію" Збройних сил на 10 років.
У ній нова команда визначила пріоритети реформ відповідно до віянь часу.
Хоч і нерадикальні.
Обіцянку про професійну армію Володимир Зеленський та його підлеглі
жодним чином не конкретизували.
Загороднюк був міністром недовго.
Вже у березні 2020-го його звільнили без пояснення необхідності такої зміни.
Військове відомство очолив Андрій Таран - генерал, 4 роки тому звільнений у запас.
Він не дуже публічний та вже запам'ятався суперечливою заявою
про начебто неможливість перейняти усі стандарти НАТО, яку так і не прояснив.
Таран зупинив багаторічну співпрацю з так званим Проєктним офісом реформ.
Члени офісу - неурядові аналітики - працювали над стратегією Збройних сил.
Їхня робота оплачувалась з бюджету.
Однак у цілому курс на стандарти НАТО і участь
в усіх спільних програмах з альянсом зберігаються.
Обсяги військової допомоги зі США зросли.
Цього року Україна отримала протитанкові ракетні установки "джавелін"
та інше військове обладнання на суму понад 60 мільйонів доларів.
До "покращень" експерти зараховують визначення пріоритетів переозброєння армії.
Тепер орієнтуються на сучасні засоби розвідки та радіоелектронної боротьби,
протиповітряну оборону.
Разом з тим, проведений Зеленським кадровий струс
дозволив нарешті розпочати давно очікувані реформи в "Укроборонпромі".
Не припинилась і розробка вітчизняних протикорабельних ракет "Нептун".
Виділено рекордні 30 мільярдів гривень на нову техніку.
Втім, армії поки не до крутих "візій" на кшталт "москітної доктрини"
з  безпілотниками та бойовими роботами.
В реальності ж ставка робиться на те, щоб подолати проблеми з нестачею кораблів
на флоті та протиракетних систем, кажуть експерти.
Зеленський надав чинності важливим змінам у системі управління армією,
які започаткував Порошенко.
Генштаб тепер відповідає за підготовку, розвиток та забезпечення військ,
а командує армією Головнокомандувач.
Також в армії з'явились "рекрути" і "штаб-сержанти", і не стало "прапорщиків".
"Полк" став називатися "бригадою".
Обидва кроки приводять Збройні сили у відповідність зі стандартами НАТО.
Власне, конфлікт з Росією Зеленський спробував вирішити у безкровний спосіб.
Демілітаризація проявлялась в усьому.
Зеленський вирішив не проводити у День незалежності військовий парад
- традиція, притаманна радше тоталітарним країнам.
Однак цим спровокував звинувачення у "зраді" .
та альтернативну ходу учасників бойових дій - Марш захисників
Силовикам Зеленський наказав почати, по суті, одностороннє виконання
передбаченого Мінськими угодами розведення військ на Донбасі.
Словесна сутичка з ветеранами АТО у Золотому на Луганщині додатково
загострила напругу в стосунках з патріотично налаштованою частиною суспільства,
і не в останню чергу з солдатами.
Експерти ж критикують розведення сил як легковажне, опоненти називають зрадою.
Проте ці миротворчі зусилля Зеленського принципово ситуацію з окупованими територіями
на користь України не змінили.
Кількість атак та диверсійостаннім часом лише збільшилась.
Україна на передовій щомісяця втрачає півтора десятки бійців.
Водночас бойовий дух війська підривається дифамацією колишніх авторитетів,
а також п'ятого президента Порошенка і екскомандувача ВМС Воронченка.
Зокрема, йдеться про порушену справу за спробу українських кораблів
пройти через Керченську протоку в 2018-му році.
Це стало першим випадком неприхованої агресії Росії на морі.
Порошенка обвинувачують у державній зраді і перевищенні влади,
бо він, мовляв, свідомо віддав наказ морякам про походження протоки,
щоб ескалювати ситуацію.
Також суперечливі сигнали посіяли обшуки у ракетних військах 1 липня,
у справі про порушення у закупівлі спецприладів.
Дефіцит комунікації щодо цих справ - одна з проблем.
Це відбувається за умов, коли деякі експерти кажуть про новий
пік ескалації конфлікту на Донбасі після Іловайська та Дебальцевого.
Аналітики застерігають про велику імовірність подальших диверсій
та навіть вторгнення російських військ.
Якщо перші сто днів президентства Зеленського давали експертам підстави для оптимізму
та тривожних очікувань рівною мірою, то через рік оптимізму поменшало.
Та все ж аналітики відзначають, що важливі тенденції у Збройних силах,
закладені після 2014 року, збереглися. І явних підстав "розганяти зраду" поки немає.